لا يختلف اثنان على نجوميه واسطوريات كل
من
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي والبرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو في عالم كره القدم حتى
وان لم يفوزاء بكاس العالم ولانها قد تكون
الاخيره بشكل كبير لميسي وكريستيانو يفعل
نجمان لتحقيق لقب كاس العالم المقامه
حاليا في دوله قطر وفي حال فشل الارجنتين
والبرتغال في تحقيق هذا الحلم سينظم كل من
ميسي وكريستيانو رونالدو الى كوكب اخرى من
نجوم الكره المستديره ممن لم يحقق كاس
العالم مع منتخباتهم رغم تحقيقهم القبن
كثيره مع اندياتهم والقابا اخرى فرديه على
راسهم اللاعب الهولندي يوهان كرويف الملقب
بالهولندي الطائر الذي استطع نجمه مع نادي
برشلونه واقتنس الكره الذهبيه ثلاث مرات
وكانت كروز قاده قوسين او ادنى من طاقه
اللقى في مونديال عام 1974 لكن منتخب
هولندا خسر النهائي اثنين واحد امام
المانيا الغربيه ان ذلك
الاسبانيه راؤول غونزاليس هو الاخر لم يدق
طعم الفوز بكاس العالم رغم مشاركته في
ثلاث نسخ متتاليه بنهائيات كاس العالم
اعوام
1998 2002 و 2006 وفي نسخه مونديال 2010
التي حقق فيها المنتخب الاسباني لقد كاس
العالم لم يتم استدعاء النجم جونزاليس من
قبل المدرب
وفي انجلترا هناك النجمان مايكل اوبن
والديفيد بيكهام حيث شارك الثنائي مع
منتخب انجلترا في ثلاث نسخ متتاليه بكاس
العالم اعوام
1990 2002 و2006 ولم يحقق البطوله وهناك
ايضا الايطاليه روبيرتو باجيو الذي لعب مع
منتخب بلا في ثلاث نهائيات لكاس العالم
وتعتبر نسخه 1994 افضل مشاركه لباجيو
عندما قاد ايطاليا الى النهائي امام
البرازيل وانتهت المباراه بالتعادل السلبي
وتم اللجوء حينها لركلات الترجيح التي
اضاع فيها باجيو ضربه جزاء اهدت اللقب
للبرازيل وهنالك كل من الارجنتيني
الارجنتينيين طبعا باتيستوتا وريكل مي
والالماني
وكان البرتغالي لويس فيغو هم ايضا شاركوا
في اكثر من النسخه لكاس العالم لكنهم لم
يستطيعوا تحقيق اللقب
[موسيقى]